on Saturday morning receiver Antonio
Brown asked the Raiders to release him
and within just a few hours they did so
what does that mean moving forward for
both the team and the player as to the
Raiders they still may end up owing him
more than 29 million dollars in
guaranteed money that was the commitment
that was made in March after a new deal
was signed following a trade from
Pittsburgh to Oakland and a fight surely
will be coming from brown and from the
Players Union as to whether or not the
Raiders are entitled to avoid paying
that money as to Brown he becomes a free
agent he can sign with anyone the
question is who will want him and how
much will they offer given that the
season is just about to begin and it
won't be easy to plug him in but that
talent always will attract someone look
for an Tonio Brown to end up getting his
third chance somewhere sooner rather
than later
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports